I asked to to leave because my heart
really wasn't in it Hollywood a tough
Biz to break into an easy one to want to
leave and a hard one to actually
it sounds like these actors jumped ship
at the first chance they got ready to
find out who was done with their TV
shows before the conclusion I don't want
to survive number one Bridgerton reggae
Jean page left Bridgerton because he was
Perfection he was actually invited back
to the show but he felt the love story
was wrapped up so perfectly why should
he come back plus he's such a big star
now he could basically get whatever he
wanted he said I have nothing but
excitement for Bridgerton continuing to
steam train off and Conquer The Globe
but there is also value in completing
these arcs and sticking the landing
number two Game of Thrones Sophie Turner
made it to the final episode of Game of
Thrones but that isn't what she wanted
she freaking loved the show but it was
out of love that she wanted an awesome
gruesome end for her character Sansa
Stark she said if you're on Game of
Thrones and you don't have a cool death
scene then what's the point it would be
really disappointing if I go to to the
end and I was just okay number three the
office the story of Steve Carell's exit
from the office is a lazy one when
contracts came due to be renegotiated
Corel didn't sign stating he wanted to
spend more time with his family but the
company running the office was on
shifting Sands and the new execs didn't
understand how much of a beating heart
Corral was on the show turns out they
didn't even try to get him to sign
number four Community we probably can't
expect Troy to make a reappearance in
the movie Donald Glover has had so much
going for him that he really just
doesn't need some quirky comedy to make
it in the biz obviously and while we all
fondly remember Troy and all bed in the
morning as fun on screen it was turmoil
behind the scenes with Dan Harmon being
considered difficult and Chevy Chase
getting fired from the show honestly who
needs the childish drama when your
childish Gambino we we can only imagine
what could have been though
number five the force awakens Harrison
Ford was not bored of Han Solo not at
all he admitted I think it's fitting use
of the character I've been arguing for
Han Solo to die for about 30 years not
because I was tired of him or because he
was boring but his sacrifice for the
other characters would lend gravitas and
emotional weight that doesn't work so
well when people prefer the original to
the new characters though
why Harrison why number six Gossip Girl
the people Taylor Momsen worked with had
intense opinions about her disrespectful
attitude on set a brat who annoyed
everybody she was always on her phone
she was dropping lines turns out it's
because she didn't even want to act you
know what that's a good reason at 12
years old not to be so great at your job
she said I started modeling it too and
then acting at three and then Gossip
Girl when I was 12. so I wasn't really
making my own decisions when I got to a
place where I realized I was in control
of my own life and had found the right
band and everything was coming to
fruition it wasn't even a question I was
going to quit my day job I came to set
every day with a [ __ ] guitar but I'm
very lucky that the producers were nice
enough to write me out allow me to tour
and pursue my passion because they very
easily could have told me to go [ __ ]
myself and keep me on the show XOXO
number 7. Gray's Anatomy after 11 season
of Gray's Anatomy Patrick Dempsey
decided it was finally time to go he
found the show all-consuming of his time
and he wasn't able to spend it with his
family like he'd wanted actually he said
that he should have moved on a couple of
years earlier in the book How to Save a
Life The Inside Story of Gray's Anatomy
the former executive producers paint a
slightly more dramatic story supposedly
Patrick was terrorizing the show
complaining about how time consuming it
was alright that adds up with what he
said too but also he was butting heads
with Ellen Pompeo and Shonda Rhimes he
did eventually get brought back in in
season 17 for a few coma episodes so it
couldn't have been that bad on set
number eight One Tree Hill Chad Michael
Murray left One Tree Hill because his
contract came due to be renegotiated and
he had no interest in sticking around
however he was caught on camera saying
they're not bringing me back next year
because because they want to save money
yikes he returned for the final season
though so he mustn't have been too upset
about it do you even know what a
write-off is number nine Parks and
Recreation at the point Paul Schneider
left Parks and Rec had not taken off yet
as he put it the show hadn't really
found its footing but it did eventually
because even his jealousy is apparent
he'd said I mean decidedly they have the
[ __ ] first lady in the show he
admitted further you know I signed up
for a specific character that was
changed in mid-season and it became a
character with a lot less to do and all
of a sudden I was kind of confused
initially they had plans to bring Paul
back but nobody expected guest stars Rob
Lowe and Adam Scott to really become
Staples of the show suddenly there was
no need for Mark brendanoquitz who do
you think is superior Ben or Mark number
10 the 100 Ricky Whittle quit the 100
because he found that it was just
impossible to work with show Runner
Jason Rothenberg Ricky said that
Rothenberg abused his position to make
his own job untenable and he belittled
both Ricky and his character Lincoln
Ricky Whittle did not leave to take up a
role in American Gods he'd already made
the decision to go before accepting the
new role number 11 Parks and Recreation
not every story is a sad one and it kind
of worked in everyone's favor except
maybe the fans to have Rashida Jones
leave when she did the arcs of Ann
Perkins and Rob Lowe's Chris Traeger had
concluded but Rashida wasn't just
leaving because of that she had a ton of
opportunities coming her way she kept
having to pass up because of her acting
commitments opportunities to work behind
the camera executive producer Mike Shore
said so it's a big happy Mutual hugfest
celebration number 12. Gray's Anatomy it
was extremely difficult for Justin
Chambers to leave Gray's Anatomy however
he wanted to diversify his acting roles
and career choices he left on a good
knows but it's definitely important not
to stick around one roll too long or
it's hard for anybody to see you as
something else and give you a chance
number 13 Breaking Bad Ian Norris asked
if his character could be often the
first half of season five of Breaking
Bad because of scheduling conflicts he
said would it be interesting if Hank
died in the first eight they said no we
kind of need you for the last eight
we've been building that up for the last
five years obviously I'm glad that they
did the scheduling sorted itself out
number 14. Gray's Anatomy Kyler Lee left
Gray's Anatomy for her family she loved
the casting crew but honestly five years
is enough sometimes she said I mean I
cried for hours after we had finished
filming just letting go it's letting go
of a part of yourself but I think it was
handled really well I thought it was a
beautiful way to go number 15 the
handmaid's tale Alexis Bledel who plays
Emily stepped away from her role in the
penultimate season of the handmaid's
tale and her leaving is steeped in
mystery all she said was after much
thought I felt I had to step away from
the handmaid's tale at this time she
gave her speech about being grateful to
the crew and gone why do you think she
left some actors see acting as a job and
not a dream then there's those who are
so passionate and intense that they want
their character written off as a gut
punch to the fans what write-off are you
still not over let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things